[Music]
in argue for me news submitted by
subliminal sublime Oh Oh what they're so
genius
you can now hire a total stranger to
argue on your behalf isn't that a lawyer
that sounds like a lawyer no the best
person to argue for you would be a girl
on PMS a dumb person
oh yes dumb people just frustrates them
don't people love that [ __ ] genius
you don't need an intelligent person
because the intelligent option will get
frustrated with a dumb person yeah you
need to get somebody on Twitter this is
the dumbest thing and hire them look
almost smart dumb person like it's so
done that's like--that's strategically
good you're trying to piss me off aren't
you oh my god that's the most genius
[ __ ] you've ever said thank you what's
the culture huh it's called dumbass for
justice dumbass because when you're in
the middle of the argument you realize
how dumb someone is you feel stupid yeah
you're like oh man I just realized this
person doesn't have to have the capacity
to understand what I'm saying and I
can't believe I put so much energy into
this and you go [ __ ] and now what do you
do I mean you what do you do does you
feel like you're the one that's been had
yeah you can play did this to myself
yeah cuz sometimes ba+
some of his training clips and there
will be a comment saying like dude you
better [ __ ] keep your hands and do
why are you doing this and I click on
their profile and they're like morbidly
obese with the gas mask on how about you
just learn how to live dude
Chinese online marketplace called Tao
bow tie oh god maybe my kid that how
about is huge over there it's like eBay
but it's yeah it's a bailer Amazon it's
both it's like eBay it seems like honey
Baba's huge but I was like the eBay so
Ali Baba's like Amazon and Taobao is
later eBay yeah how about when I come
how about give me the power so now
they're offering people a chance to hire
a professional quarrel err argue on
their hire any Latino [ __ ] oh yeah we
can't you can't be thrown the fisticuffs
though you know me and they know we
don't we just [ __ ] go what and what
were the hoops so that you could see how
I do that it's only a latina service and
the bigger the hoops are the higher the
tier of the pay if you get that caught
on something oh who are you arguing with
are you arguing with who it's like I'm
arguing with a lawyer well we have our
higher tier hoops over here for an extra
fee we'll get the gold ones out the
bamboo wants to talk to you
that's the black belt oh my god time out
what is that is that jokes or not I
don't know why does it look like it's in
the 90s now it looks like the [ __ ]
you know in like no G Star Wars with a
droid
roll out so they're saying you'll be
able to browse through dozens of offers
from various professional portals my
name is Jiang I never lost an argument
in my life
my name is Cheng and I always wings like
you need me to argue science I got it so
like professors I like [ __ ] fighting
and [ __ ] you hired based on what their
degrees are yeah cuz if you need a
specialty is like are you are you always
stuck in an argument over sports guess
what oh that's good you know yeah so
they're saying that you can hire someone
or anywhere from five yuan which is
about 74 cents and 20 yuan which is
that's three dollars I work with cabbage
so they're saying that this is not done
in person it's all through the phone or
texting it's all in WeChat yeah so then
they're also saying that an angry phone
call or text message can cost 20 yuan
which is $3.00 a whole day of spam calls
cost 40 yuan damn it's just harassment
and then bombarding your to your Atari
get phone with hate calls 24/7 will cost
$100 God that I mean I could definitely
do this though I mean that's the thing
they're saying that hundred Yuans
it's not a lot that's like just over 10
bucks that's dope and you could bug
someone all day for 24/7 hate calls for
just over $10 bucks
that's [ __ ] Tom are you just thinking
who in the list I want to work there
they are saying that the payment app LEP
they are super strict about services
that could be considered harassment
what's the Chinese definition of
harassment yeah because I don't think
there's a line for that it's murder
that's the line you cute you try to kill
anybody
no okay there's a fine line between
shame and harassment and that's it for
me that's that's that's the service that
they're offering that's a pretty cool
service good job that's it she dropped
the mic on this I feel like this is
something that would work really well in
the United States and they should create
a Italian organization that does
something like this oh no this is
basically harassment right or like if
it's like kind of like a Mean Girls move
like if you don't like this girl because
she took your man or whatever then you
be that's all I need to know is I need
to figure out how to develop something
that make me that type of money you want
this type of money you came up with
something right now that I like dumb
people arguing Oh dumb asses for justice
yeah I like that one I really like the
profiles like I'm real dumb now I'm even
dumber but you got a screen um yeah you
better aren't you like you gotta like
get into argument and when you're just
[ __ ] pissed cuz out dumb that it's
like you're hired it would be crazy cuz
it's like your resume is based on stuff
that people know it's really stupid like
for example I'm a flat earther it's like
cool I don't activate my kids got you
eight years of Scientology coming at you
yeah that one's really good I'm
illogical I always win argument I think
you're just an Asian dad dad I'll piss
you off
Asian moms will piss you off those two
give the Asian parents some work you get
bored dude you got to start that my dad
does this to me
he calls you and harasses you everyday
this call
give work we need to give vacations nice
you don't work I want to know that how
do you make it a nap I don't know how to
in today's world you hire developers now
what is it developer a person that
creates colder one day well let's have
an argument right now let's see how is
the dumb way huh who's that oh we're
gonna my tactic just go ahead what's the
subject what's a category man parking
outdoors yeah okay why are you parking
your office in my driveway
what is it driveway you're looking at it
it's outside of my house you're [ __ ]
damn dude also need a second question
even knowing what the house the veins
are popping for the intonation changes
like I think the best tactic for dumb
people is they think that they got one
up on you but they totally missed what's
going on
yeah but they thought they win can you
give us an example no it's too complex
his two kids yeah yeah it's so dumb it's
hard to replica can I try try it okay
try it let's just try and you know that
if you succeed there's examples but I
can't think of every yeah yeah go give
me an argument someone like when you
trying to explain you mean I get this
microwave zapped all the nutrients out
of food of course cuz of all the heat
you ain't yeah you don't anything else I
don't know the truth it'll be an
argument like this it'll be it'll be
like you need to drink more water and
then they'll be like but I drink soda
right and they will soda is really bad
for you because it has a lot of [ __ ] all
these like oh yeah but it's a liquid
just like no no but because of those
enemies that yeah but it's a liquid so
technically it's water I think that's
what y'all means no no it's like this
it's like so so tell me your water line
okay uh I drink a lot of water because I
drink soda David let me tell you
something
it's the same thing no it's not just
come on don't worry that's what I'm
talking about that's annoying as that
[ __ ] egotistical I [ __ ] know but
it's like wait you got to do an eye roll
yeah and like their day they believe
that you're an idiot and I'm just like I
can't believe this is happening tell you
right now
Asian dad for sure cuz my dad I remember
he was telling me is like you know
what's happening in the Marine Corps and
then I'm like dad I'm in the Marines and
then he's like bar do you read the
newspaper in the Marine Corps I hear
[ __ ] straight from the Secretary of
Defense who talks to the president talks
of the Commandant talks to my company
clan you don't know he goes you don't
know yeah but still his newspaper I'm
like oh my [ __ ] yeah that's the same
type of [ __ ] that I would have when when
I started YouTube and then my dad was
telling me how to run my YouTube there's
something that I I do it nobody else
even nobody even we didn't really know
yeah I mean and we were the only ones
that had a source of information how to
work this yeah we're figuring out yeah
and they're like no that's not how you
do it David let me tell you something
here this company called go for broke
you know what you sell condoms that's
what my dad said and I said so you want
me to sell a condom that says go for
broke on it are you stupid
yeah comedy you want to try to be funny
the whole damn what if that was me go
for broke side and then it's just a hole
in it and it's for [ __ ] girls who
wanted not the basketball stars that's
pretty good you are condoms with holes
does the deceptive condom yeah deceptive
this dissing the deceptive kansai
transformer plate something there yeah
but she didn't name kids or something
else did your stupid conscious Korean
ninjas we come into the shadows did you
guys have other names with hinges
besides kynges
before it was candy was called ANBU
black ops smells way too nerdy really
long as it is a jack from Naruto
yeah yeah all the black ops are like the
stealthy like pretty much the Secret
Service is the CIA
you know I'm they like take away their
names their identities always were
masked
who thought of the name ANBU black
we just [ __ ] love in order to like
crazy during that time and then we just
thought that it would be fun to come in
unassuming we didn't even let them put
us on the flyer cuz if people would have
known we were doing a project it might
have been maybe the expectations would
have been somewhere but I no no don't
tell anybody and we'll come in like
stealth come on did you guys come in
with the ninja run damn near I wore like
a Akatsuki rub sleeping very nerdy so I
don't know or talk about this I lost a
lot of respect for you right the same I
lost my view since you didn't take your
dad's business idea those genius it was
actually pretty terrible and go for
broke is gone now
[Music]